wir schauen nach minsk vor die situation
weiterhin angespannt ist die menschen
gehen noch immer auf die straße um gegen
den diktator lukaschenko vorzugehen sie
wollen endlich eine revolution im land
trotzdem werden sie jetzt weiterhin
niedergeknüppelt und festgenommen
die proteste in minsk reißen nicht ab
nur die demonstranten kommen teils nicht
weit die oman die prügel truppen von
diktator lukaschenko reagieren brutal
[Applaus]
tausende studenten sind auf die straße
gegangen
an ihrem ersten tag nach den
semesterferien viele der jungen menschen
zeigen die rot-weiße flagge der
revolution gegen das regime rufen
lukaschenko muss weg es lebe belarus und
verschwinde
doch offenbar war das regime diesmal
vorbereitet führte hunderte
einsatztruppen an die unis hochschulen
und studentengruppen heran
in den größtenteils nur die flucht vor
den schlägern und berüchtigten
folterknechten der diktatur blick die
weissrussen zeigen deutlich was sie von
ihrem machthaber halten
oppositionsführerin und eigentliche wahl
siegerin swetlana scaglia sagt warum die
leute auf die straße gehen want to
himself unsere bürger wollen sich
zuallererst sicher fühlen und
respektiert und ernst genommen werden
vom staat und den machthabern und das
ist unmöglich mit diesem präsidenten
wir haben jetzt in angst gelebt für mehr
als 20 jahre
jetzt reicht es unseren menschen die
hauptbotschaft der menschen an
lukaschenko ist tritt ab den
demonstranten bleibt weiterhin nur die
hoffnung und der wunsch auf ein abtreten
des diktators bislang hält sich
lukaschenko auch durch die unterstützung
putins
ein aus mainz berichtet für uns bild
vize paul ronzheimer paul du hast diese
jagd 10 auf den strassen miterlebt was
genau spielt sich gerade in weißrussland
vor allem in minsk ab daniele man muss
sich das so vorstellen wenn man ihr
morgens aus der tür geht und sich einen
kaffee holen bildern kann es passieren
dass man auf einem der opfer care
straßen plötzlich diese jagd 10
mitbekommt das sind die mittlerweile
berühmten muss man schon sagen männer
von mondi spezialeinheit des diktators
die zu demonstrationen geschickt wird
und dann gehen sie raus und nehmen
wahllos menschen mit wir haben da
gestern brutalste szenen gesehen wie
auch gerade in den videos gezeigt hat
und gestern das ist eine ganz neue
qualität als die kontrollen und
universitäten gegangen sind und die
jungen menschen rausgeholt haben es sind
die jungen menschen die hier für
freiheit auf die straße gehen und
lukaschenko will das nicht länger
zulassen
man muss er leider sagen solche videos
solche aufnahmen sehen wir jetzt jede
woche aus - woher nehmen die menschen
diesen unglaublichen mut trotzdem weiter
auf die straße zu gehen
diese frage stelle ich den menschen hier
immer wieder und alle beantworten sie
damit dass sie einfach genug haben und
nicht darüber nachdenken was das ganze
für konsequenzen für sie haben kann
natürlich wenn man sieht wie brutal sie
verprügelt werden wenn man die folter
geschichten hört von vielen menschen die
dann von romont mitgenommen wurden dann
stellt man sich diese frage woher nehmen
diese jungen menschen die mut aber ich
glaube hier ist eine dynamik entstanden
die kaum aufzuhalten ist und dass ganz
besondere daran die menschen sind immer
noch friedlich hier auf den straßen was
kann deutschland jetzt tun was kann
europa für diese menschen tun
ich denke kanzlerin angela merkel müsste
viel entschiedener vorgehen
sie hat am anfang der krise fehler
gemacht weil sie geglaubt hat dass man
putin nicht zu sehr provozieren soll mit
dem narrativ dass es irgend einer
einmischung des westens gibt aber putin
hat dann am ende gesagt es gab diese
einmischung also ihm ist völlig egal was
die k
man sagt oder tut ist mein gefühl
deshalb denke ich deutschland sollte
auch personenbezogenen sanktionen gegen
lukaschenko durchsetzen die gibt es
bislang noch nicht es gibt nur
sanktionen diesem umfeld betreffen ich
denke man sollte sich als präsidenten
anerkennen dass wir ein großes großes
zeichen der eu möglicherweise um zu
sagen wir hätten diese wahlen nur nicht
nicht an sondern wir sagen auch diese
frau ist die legitime präsidenten und
dazu darüber muss diskutiert werden
sanktionen gegen putin gegen sein umfeld
für das was er hier in belarus tut
vielen dank paul ronzheimer live aus
minsk dankeschön